If you're accustomed to keeping things in the fog in general,
you're going to keep yourself in the fog with regards to your investments
because it's some sense everything you do is an investment,
right?
I mean,
some of it's quantified in monetary terms,
but you're always investing in one manner or another.
And so I think if your character is being disrupted by your persistent attempts
to deceive yourself about the nature of reality,
you're going to be a financial train wreck.
And I mean,
I've certainly seen that in my clinical practice.
I've seen people burn through amounts of money that you wouldn't think someone
could burn through in that short a period of time because of self deceptive
blindness.